on a donc découvert des traces de sang
dans la voiture d'un des voisins des
jubilaires ça c'est une vraie avancée
dans l' enquête comment ça se fait qu'on
ne les ai pas trouvés avant
cccc trace de sang n'ait pas vérifié
partout ben en fait si vous voulez c'est
une enquête qui a démarré ya maintenant
un an il ya beaucoup d'investigations
qui ont été fait et ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que cédric jubilaire a
démultiplié les pistes qui ont conduit
les magistrats instructeurs à exploit
rey a explosé à exploit ray quand je
suis arrivé avec sa muse et les deux
c'est très bien donc vous avez bien
compris qu'il y avait énormément de
pistes à exploiter et à explorer et que
ces pistes l'ont été pendant un an donc
ça a demandé énormément de temps et
cette fois ci bien effectivement il ya
peut-être
la phrase de trop qui a été lâché à son
codétenu et qui mène cette fois ci à une
piste très sérieux rappeler la phrase de
trouver juste on va rappeler moi j'ai
une question cédric jubile as qu'il
avait déjà eu un passé judiciaire aucun
alors non il n'y a pas de passé
judiciaire des comptes mais ça tu me dis
je me dis donc ce garçon en fait il a
réussi à commettre comme il le dit pas
ce qui c'est lui qui le dit il dit j'ai
réussi le crime parfait et il avoue dit
il excédé il a multiplié les pistes pour
berner tout le monde etc c'est un truc
de fou c'est à dire que le gars il y
aurait pensé bien sûr avant tout
manigancé alors qu'il n'avait jamais eu
un passé voilà de criminels ou cocasse
c'est fou ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle
était très amoureux de delphine d'accord
ça on est sûr qu'ils étaient très
amoureux d'elle film et on sait qu'ils
vivaient dans une relation toxique est
dans une relation
dans laquelle elle voulait plus évolués
s'agit alors c'est ça l'histoire parce
qu vraiment pour les gens qui nous
rejoignent et qui connaissent pas bien
la faire gilles est ce que vous pouvez
nous l'a résumé parce que oui donc les
jubilaires sont un couple qui avait des
difficultés et cédric jubilent à
peut-être qu'il est mis en examen donc
on verra ensuite mais a senti que sa
femme voulait le quitter et donc du coup
elle a disparu mystérieusement la nuit
du 15 au 16 décembre 2020 et plus aucune
trace c'est ça qui est saisissant donc
après moult péripéties il a été mis en
examen
ce couple se déchiraient on a parlé d'un
amant on a parlé d'autres personnes mais
pour le moment dans l'état du dossier il
n'y a que lui qui est mis en examen il
ya d'autres pistes qui s'ouvrent à
chaque fois il se referme pour le moment
ces pistes mènent à lui mais il dément
vous avez parlé il ya un instant m batik
de ce qu'ils avaient révélé à son
codétenu ce que vous pouvez rappeler les
conversation qu'il aurait eue avec son
côté pas ce qui va se passer dans ce
dossier c'est que dans un premier temps
cédric jubilaire va démultiplier les
pistes en disant allez regarder du côté
de la manche aller regarder du côté de
la femme de l'amant peut-être qu'elle
est partie qu'elle est parti à
l'étranger que sage et c'est donc cpie
cela vous commandez énormément de temps
est arrivé en détention il va faire la
connaissance d'un détenu à qui va se
confier ce détenu le prenant un peu sous
son aile parce qu'effectivement dans la
détention et bien les gens les les
codétenus de ce fait cédric le juglar
n'est pas très apprécié et donc on va
voir quelqu'un qui va le prendre un peu
sous son aile et le prenant sous son
aile il va se laisser aller à lui faire
quelques confidences et parmi ces
confidences il va lui dire écoute je
suis pas assez stupide pour prendre le
véhicule mon véhicule pour pour pour
cacher le corps de delphine c'est
effectivement moi qui ai tué delphine et
j'ai pris j'ai pris une voiture blanche
et donc à la suite de ces confidences
avec les officiers de police judiciaire
les enquêteurs vont commencer à regarder
dans l'entourage de cédric jubilaire qui
aurait une voiture blanche et on va
trouver qu'effectivement un de ses amis
à une voiture blanche
et que pire que ça non seulement il a
une voiture blanche mais en plus cette
voiture blanche il laisse toujours les
clés sur la voiture nuitées jours parce
qu'on est à cagnac les mines et a aucune
délinquance et donc ils laissent les
voitures et les clefs sur son véhicule
mythe et j'aurai donc on va un peu
s'intéresser on va avancer on va
chercher à savoir est-ce que
hypothétiquement il aurait pu prendre là
le véhicule sans que le propriétaire le
sache et là le propriétaire va dire non
seulement c'est totalement impossible
qu'il ait pris le véhicule mais plus que
ça une fois puisque ce propriétaire du
véhicule laissé aussi sa maison tout le
temps ouverte et donc une fois cédric
juin on va rentrer dont le domicile de
ce dernier alors que celui ci est en
train de dormir pour dira-t-il avoir un
morceau de shit à fumer et donc bah on
est dans un contexte très spécifique
donc l'hypothèse selon laquelle il
aurait pu prendre ce véhicule pour
transporter le corps de delphine et
reposer ce véhicule à ce même endroit
est totalement plausible aujourd'hui
c'est intéressant ce que dit m batik
alors syrie d'armes à dunkerque vous
êtes donc policiers et vous êtes un ami
de cédric jubilaire vous avez rencontré
comment cédric jubilaire le connaissez
de monde alors cédric jubilaire c'est
une affaire assez incroyable puisque moi
je les ai rencontrés par hasard en
jouant à un jeu en ligne s'appelle game
of thrones conquest
et c'est un jeu de type
to win en fait il faut payer des options
pour avancer un peu et rapidement on
n'était pas beaucoup de joueurs français
sur la sur la plateforme donc via le
tchat on a pu échanger faire
connaissance et je voyais son personnage
qui avançait très très vite beaucoup
plus vite que le mien évidemment parce
que moi je mettais pas d'argent dedans
et donc
il ya des fois où j'ai vu l'opportunité
de parler avec sa fusée mais comment tu
fais pour trouver tout cet argent m6
luce pas facile parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une réduction ça coûte beaucoup je
suis obligé de pour avancer plus il faut
payer à chaque fois pendant la ccin
payer des intentions mais à peu près les
solutions alors ça il ya des packs qu'on
achète ça peut aller jusqu'à 100 euros
le pack et il pouvait en acheter
plusieurs par semaine et en fait il faut
vous prenez une attaque vous perdiez vos
soldats et puis si vous payez vous les
refuser vie de suite et en fait ça
permettait de repartir dans le jeu
immédiatement et donc lui par rapport à
ça me dit bon je fais plein de deux
chantiers aux blacks qui était plaquiste
xavi il fut mais également du cannabis
donc c'était aussi quelque chose qui lui
coûtait de l'argent se mérite et il a
beaucoup été fait focaliser sur sa
consommation de cannabis par rapport au
coût que ça pouvait avoir sur sur son
couple ma réalité les gens ligne lui
côté beaucoup plus d'argent et mettez
beaucoup plus à mal ses finances et son
addiction au cannabis c'est incroyable
c'était donc si vous voulez par rapport
à par rapport à ça donc nous on a on a
fait connaissance au début virtuellement
réellement après ensuite lui l'habitat
cagnac-les-mines moi j'suis toulousain
d'origine dont même si maintenant je
suis en région parisienne on avait
l'occasion de parler de tout et rien on
s'appréciait vraiment et
tout le temps moi j'ai pu vraiment voir
l'amour qu'il avait pour sa femme
delphine qui pour lui était vraiment son
repère je crois que sans elle il aurait
été incapable de vivre tout simplement
ils ont été complètement perdus et quand
j'ai vu ce qu'il s'était passé au niveau
de la faire moi je vous avouerai que je
n'y ai jamais cru à la culpabilité de
eric gillard avec pourquoi vous l'avez
rencontré comme une fois vous avez vu
combien de fois je les mois je les ai vu
une fois en vrai une réunion de gamers
et ensuite j'ai eu plusieurs fois au
téléphone mais genre toutes les semaines
ils vont raconter ce qui se passe avec
sa femme vous disait qu'il avait qu il
était très amoureux qu'ils avec la
soupçonner d'avoir un amant alors ils
étaient ils étaient très amoureux d'elle
ça oui je sais qu'elle lui faisait
beaucoup de reproches par rapport
effectivement à la maison qu'ils
n'allaient pas par rapport à tout
l'argent qu'ils mettaient ailleurs que
dans son foyer parce qu'ils aient pris
des engagements pour ça pour sa maison
il avait beaucoup de rêves il voulait
faire beaucoup de choses mais c'est vrai
que j'aime bien c'est quelqu'un qui
voulait faire beaucoup de choses à la
fois et qui du coup ne pouvait pas hélas
ce toutou suivre en même temps et c'est
très important tout ça pourquoi parce
que quand il a été mis en examen moi je
ne crois pas un instant à sa culpabilité
parce que pour faire le meurtre parfait
il faut vraiment être très réfléchi très
méthodique il faut avoir la capacité
mais psychologiquement de pouvoir que
vous êtes policier oui tout à fait et
fort d'avoir la possibilité de prendre
en compte tous les différents éléments
pour moi le meurtre parfait et donc
quelqu'un aurait pu être celui qui l'a
commis parce que ça n'a pas été défini
c'est la sphère digues et à toulouse par
exemple en avait un un professeur
émérite de droit quelqu'un qui avait
vraiment un niveau intellectuel qui lui
permettait de pouvoir faire ce genre
d'entreprise mais là cédric jubile art
c'est monsieur tout le monde c'est le
plaquiste c'est le gars qui travaille
sur un chantier c'est le gars qui est
perdu quand il n'a pas sa femme à côté
de lui et
je ne le vois absolument pas aller
réfléchir à comment il va réussir à
passer tous les pièges de la police
scientifique notamment pour pouvoir ne
pas être repéré et l'on dit oui il donne
plein de pistes il donne des pistes il
dit oui peut-être ce site est ce là mais
moi si je mets un cadavre dans votre
placard et que je vous accuse vous allez
donner des dizaines de pistes possibles
c'est pas vous donc forcément à chaque
fois ça va retomber à zéro on va on va
être sur quelque chose qui ne tient pas
la route et sur les confidences faites
justement aux codétenus alors jacques et
un co détenu parce que je rappelle qu'il
est à l' isolement à seysses maison
d'arrêt d'ailleurs que par hasard j'ai
bien connu puisque j'ai été survie
administration pénitentiaire pendant un
an et demi sur seille ce dont je connais
le quartier d'isolement louis se situe
actuellement à l' isolement il ne voit
personne à sont des cellules
individuelles ils peuvent parler hein
pas par cellule d'accord quand vous êtes
en prison il faut arriver à se faire
respecter pour survivre à la prison pour
survivre aux autres prisonniers
donc qu'ils aient été se faire une
légende en disant qu'il a tué sa femme
pour passer pour un caïd est entre
guillemets gagner un peu le respect des
autres prisonniers d'un point de vue
sociologique cela peut s'expliquer par
contre les explications qu'il a données
comme quoi il aurait poignardé sa femme
sur le canapé et que par la suite il
aurait été mettre le corps près de la
maison qui a pris feu ça ça pose un
souci parce que en police scientifique
dès lors où il ya des traces de sang
même si voulait nettoyer on pas ce qu'on
appelle le blue star on le voit
immédiatement s'il l'avait poignardée
vous imaginez le nombre de traces de
sang qu'on aurait retrouvé sur la scène
il y en aurait eu absolument partout ça
n'a pas été le cas il ya eu ce qu'on a
focalisé sur la couette mais la couette
en réalité on s'aperçut plus tard qu'il
n'y avait strictement rien sur cette
couette qui a été lavé et enfin et je
reviens là dessus si ils l'avaient donc
tu es réellement et qu'il avait fait des
confidences aux codétenus il aurait dit
comment il l'a tuée or là à part par
étouffement ou par strangulation pour ne
pas laisser de traces il n'ya pas pour
moi d'autres possibilités or ce n'est
pas du tout ce qu'il évoque à son co
détenu s'il avait étranglé qu'il avait
prise d'un de la voiture blanche pour
l'amener plus loin je pense qu'il aurait
dit tout simplement je l'étranglé
pourquoi il doit arrêter dire je les
poignarder ça tient pas trop large mais
tous semblent l'accuser mais tous
semblent l'accuser là encore ce qu'on a
ce que veut nous raconter m batik avec
la voiture blanche la voiture qu'est le
voisin laissait toujours les pieds
dessus on a retrouvé du sang dans cette
comment vous comment vous expliquez ce
sont des liens qu'on fait ça sont des
liens qu'on fait nous de l'extérieur en
fait c'est à dire que comme je vous dis
si vous prenez un innocent et que vous
mettez un quart dans son placard vous
allez trouver des liens avec tous et on
va vous dire autrement j'avais une
voiture bleue vous allez trouver
forcément une voiture bleue dans le lot
d'amis quelqu'un aurait une il n'y a pas
vraiment d'éléments standard par exemple
le sens on sait pas si c'est non sans
mal de lui-même de quelques bogues et en
être le propriétaire qui s'est taillé je
rappelle qu'on est chez est un
toxicomane puisqu'ils consomment du
cannabis et que d'ailleurs cédric joly
l'a redit qu'il a fait non c'est la
personne qui dit qu'une fois cédric est
venue chez lui pour lui demander du shit
mais donc on est calquée sur mode de vie
marginal le le sang peut venir de lui de
n'importe qui d'autre c'est des éléments
qui sont pour moi assez peu probants en
tout cas quand une question il ya trois
jours qu'on parle du son il faut combien
de temps pour savoir parce que le sens
reims alors
ça c'est no sé nou délais en train de
regarder mais ce qui est encore plus
incroyable et ça c'est vraiment une
chose à soulever c'est que si cédric
jubile art et l'assassin bon quelques
parts emmené en prison par contre s'il
est innocent ça nous amène à sancey
nador qui lui par contre va et vient
comme il veut et moi cette affaire là
elle me rappelle une chose m rappelle
affaire d'outreau savait où on avait
quelqu'un qui avait été désigné comme
coupable qui a été enfermé parce qu'il
fallait un coupable il était le coupable
idéal et au final il a fait plusieurs
années de prison avant qu'on se rende
compte que il fallait le blanchir
surtout et moi j'ai peur de me retrouver
exactement dans le même cadre avec cette
affaire là alors m moa de batik je
rappelle les l'avocat de la famille
jubila quand vous entendez tout ça c'est
incroyable ce que nous a raconté syrie
d'armes à dunkerque et policiers en plus
qu'est-ce que vous ne répondez pas
d'abord on peut pas convoquer l'affairé
outreau à chaque fois qu'on a de la
compassion pour son ami pour son fils
pour son mari et ses dires c'est un
moment on peut pas convoquer ce dossier
là à chaque fois c'est pas possible
en revanche vous avez raison et c'est
peut-être une réflexion que j'ai eu
aussi au début du dossier en me disant
comment ce ce pauvre type pour pour le
dire de façon triviale comment ce pauvre
type aurait pu commettre ce crime
parfait est en réalité cédric jubilaire
c'est tout sauf un pauvre type c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est qui et comme le commun
des mortels et qu'on regarde 1 son
dossier scolaire quand on regarde un peu
sa vie quand on regarde un peu son vécu
cédric jubila roi tout ça cédric
jubilaire c'est quelqu'un de très
intelligent a toujours été dans ces
dossiers scolaires et des bas sur son
dossier scolaire c'est quelqu'un qui a
de très grande capacité ça a toujours
été notés les très grandes capacités et
puis un élément moi qui m'a quand même
interrogé dans ce dossier c'est que
cédric jubilaire c'est un joueur de
poker c'est un grand joueur de poker
terme genre de la lozère du samedi soir
c'est quelqu'un qui va s'inscrire dans
un club de joueurs de poker et qui va
jouer à haut niveau et donc en réalité
dans ce dossier ils se comportent du
début à la fin comme un joueur de poker
face au magistrat instructeur il bluffe
il est en pokerface il ne dit ni ne
divulgue pas ses cartes il ne dévoile
pas son jeu et donc il va attendre à
chaque fois que les magistrats
instructeurs avancent leurs cartes avant
lui même de se positionner et quand on
regarde un petit peu dans le rétroviseur
ce qui s'est passé depuis un an c'est un
joueur de poker est donc là peut-être
qu'elle a commis la faute de trop peut
être le bluff de trop et il a donné
effectivement cette indication parce
qu'on retrouve cette trace de sang dans
le véhicule de son ami et donc c'est
cette trace de son on est sûr d'une
chose c'est que delfim n'est jamais
monté dans son véhicule et donc si on
retrouve avant le 31 mars des traces de
sang qui appartiennent à delphine jubila
est bien là ça va être très difficile
pour lui et pour la défense de fer des
écrans de fumée de dire circulez ya rien
à voir alors bon c'est si les traces de
son sont celles de de delphine subit là
pour vous c'est et voilà c'est ça voilà
qu peur pour moi sa part achèvera cette
enquête qui a été rondement bien mené
parce que on peut pas dire qu'il n'y a
rien dans ce dossier que ce dossier vide
ce dossier il est tout sauf vide ce
dossier il manque effectivement et
disons le de manière très transparente
il manque encore il manque aujourd'hui
un corps ou bien il manque des aveux
alors il manque des aveux et encore mais
aujourd'hui ce dossier n'est pas vide
d'abord avant avant la disparition de
delphine jubilaire il ya toute une
attitude ya tout un climat anxiogène
entre les deux où l'attitude de cédric
jubilaire est quand même très
tendancieuse il est jaloux compulsif et
les seuils de la géolocaliser il sait
qu'elle a un amant il va regarder sur
ses comptes bancaires la lingerie
qu'elle s'achète et
hôtels dans lesquels elle va rejoindre
son amant ensuite pendant la disparition
il va y avoir cette couette qui va être
mise à trois heures du matin dans le
lave-linge alors que c'est quelqu'un de
tout sauf de très propre et de très
précieux et puis il va avoir une
attitude pendant les battues ou
finalement le sait il ne va pas
réellement chercher chercher le corps et
puis après après à ces déclarations ou à
de multiples reprises il va se présenter
comme le criminel parfait il ne va pas
le dire comme son ami le dit simplement
en détention pour se gargariser pour se
donner une certaine prestance il va le
dire à sa petite soeur il va le dire à
des amis il va leur dire en détention et
puis en détention ça ne lui sert pas
d'être le tueur de delphine parce que
les les codétenus qui hurle son nom et
qui lui en veulent lui en veulent
justement parce que potentiellement il
serait donc l'argument de cyril pour
vous il n'ya pas une seule seconde la
route je dire les gens lui hurle dessus
à l'isolément et le menacent de sortir
en promenade extérieure parce qu'il
pense qu'il est le le tueur de le
criminel de delphine donc je leur ai
tout intérêt a justement expliqué qu'il
ne l'est pas mais lui ce qui va faire
c'est qu'il va faire les confidences à
ce que des tenues qui le prend sous son
aile en dix ans effectivement c'est moi
qui ait poignardé la fim et puis ils se
gargarisent il est grisé par cette
nouvelle par cette nouvelle halle admise
en été mais alors vous allez répondre
aux nations syrie sont exemptes wii se
présente est réellement dernièrement il
se présente comme l'homme le plus connu
du tarn homme le plus connu de cagnac
les mines et il en est tout à fait
satisfait s'il ya un instant donc m
mourad ben atiq nous a dit
toutes les capacités intellectuelles que
pouvait avoir cédric jibidar notamment
que c'est un grand joueur de poker qui
faisait pas départi du dimanche à
comines hosani qu'est ce que vous lui
répondait alors plusieurs choses déjà
premièrement sur la détention
j'entends l'argumentaire de m batik mais
le soutien c'est que ça c'est un
argumentaire qui seraient recevables
entre guillemets en maison d'arrêt or là
il n'est pas dans une cellule en maison
d'arrêt il a un quartier à l' isolement
donc entre guillemets il est protégé de
ses co détenus est ce qu'à dit ce qu'a
dit aussi aux îles traumatique il a dit
vous avez vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure vous avez dit il un peu faire le
malin auprès des autres détenus claudel
de dire voilà j'ai poignardé ma femme
mais juste pour faire le mal en payons
et monsieur baticle a dit au contraire
c'est pour ça que les autres que les
autres détenus pourraient
être violents avec lui moi je trouve ça
très très très curieux parce que dans
les maisons d'arrêt autant les plus
qu'on appelle les pointeurs c'est à dire
les pédophiles sont souvent les cibles
des autres détenus qui aime bien se
faire empruntant autant les meurtriers
pas du tout quoi pas spécialement au
contraire dans la hiérarchie du détenu
dans cette sorte de sociologie parallèle
qui se fait dans le monde carcéral
les tueurs ils sont plutôt tout en haut
ils sont plutôt respectée contrairement
aux pointes heurte à dire aux pédophiles
et aux violeurs qui eux sans vraiment
tout en bas ceux sur qui tout le monde
aime bien tomber sa mise à part en ce
qui concerne les capacités énormes de
cédric jubilaire alors encore une fois
je précise
si effectivement il est
le coupable qu'il est le meurtrier il a
sa place en prison s'il n'y a pas de
problème en je ne remets pas en cause
par contre là actuellement moi je trouve
toujours qu'on est un peu limite au
niveau des preuves on n'a pas d'armé du
crime on n'a pas de corps honoré
éventuellement un pseudo mobile mail à
tous les éléments qui sont données pour
vous pour vous si les traces de son dans
la voiture du voisin corresponde à celle
de delphine subi la salle accuse ou pas
encore là par contre effectivement je
dirais qu'il faut revoir ma position
là-dessus d'accord tant de savoir mais
mais évidemment je suis pas là pour
défendre meurtrier ne sera pas moi je
suis là pour faire respecter justement
le fait qu'on a peut-être un innocent
qui en prison et donc je précise le fait
de piste et sa femme voir pour la
géolocaliser sur ses achats en ligne la
lingerie qu'elle porte et en fait c'est
le comportement de tout mari jaloux et
et trompait alors on va me dire oui mais
lui il n'était peut-être pas 100%
fidèles tout ça très bien mais une chose
qui est vraie il aimait delphine il
aimait delphine et c'était toute sa vie
et quand il a vu qu'il est en train de
perdre delphine il a perdu pied et
effectivement c'est humain j'ai envie de
dire et c'est le cas de milliers de
couples il a fait comme plein d'autres
hommes il a essayé de savoir voir ce qui
va ce qu'elle achète qu'ils voient comme
elle le fait parce que c'est une
réaction qui est spontané qui est tout
simplement humaine pour ce qui est des
parties de poker festival joue au poker
joue au poker comme il joue à autre
chose je suis moi même genre de poker
néanmoins tous les joueurs de poker ne
sont pas des grands meurtriers en
puissance un jour affronter les joueurs
de poker sam on assure qu il est juste
derrière moi ce qui est important au
poker mais voudrait qu'elle soit mais
très sympathique c'est vous savez la
position à la table quand on joue et
j'aimerais bien connaître la vôtre mais
je n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est pas
si facile je sais pas si je me fais le
porte parole des gens qui regardent la
télé ce soir mais moi j'ai un ami qui va
le pascal bataille qu'il a tué quelqu'un
il soupçonne d'avoir tué quelqu'un
jennir seront sur le plateau de cyril
hanouna je vais défendre machin vous
l'avez rencontré une fille une fois dans
une réunion de gamer c'est on parle de
deux jeux donc ok vous l'avez vous
voulez parler de temps en temps autour
de ces jeux et je me demande ce qui fait
que vous êtes aussi convaincu essayant
d'être haussier convaincant face à
l'avocat des familles et vous lui
répondez presque à gabes à armes égales
et je me pose une petite question que
j'ai peut-être la réponse à pourquoi
vous êtes là ce soir c'est que quand on
tape haute non pardon ça apporte de le
dire on disait alors c'est important
quand on reçoit quelqu'un sur le plateau
de savoir d'où ils parlent joie cyril
air demain qu'hier délégué départemental
du rassemblement national
annonce son ralliement au candidat eric
zemmour pour la présidentielle lors il
demeure également élu régional il est
exclu du groupe fn au conseil régional
du centre val de loire ce que je crois
honnêtement et je vous dis avec beaucoup
de sincérité vous êtes très sympathique
j'ai pris une photo avec vous et bien
d'autres mamans et voilà cool mais un
nombre donné est ce que vous n'êtes pas
là parce qu' on va certainement vous
retrouver sa trace en dedans de moi pour
aller bar où il est peut-être élus
candidats et c'est avec lui à un passage
télé à presque 2 millions de
téléspectateurs
et du sang je vais répondre si vous
perdez
sélectivité au fusil je suis
complètement voix sans agressivité des
plateaux télé j'en fais partie excusez
moi je rajoute que vous êtes policier
mais moi je suis vos chefs là ce soir je
vois un policier en exercice police
nationale en train de défendre un
présumé meurtrier je n'étais
pas prêt
il va bien voilà premièrement un je suis
policier oui je suis patron de syndicats
de police donc je suis en décharges
d'activité syndicale d'accord et pour
votre gouverne suite à une blessure en
service je suis actuellement en
reclassement donc pour être en police
technique et scientifique travers
d'envoyer ça ne posera aucun problème à
mes patrons je n'ai pas de paul eluard
de réserve ce n'était pas le seul
deuxièmement je ne défends pas un
criminel je suis là pour m'interroger
par rapport à quelqu'un que j'ai connu
maintenant vous me demandez si c'est pas
pour me faire de la pub non je vais vous
dire des passages télé j'en fais déjà je
suis déjà venu ici je suis déjà venu
plusieurs fois sur les plans moral que
deux ans
après j'ai annoncé mon ralliement dont
vous parliez la sueur perdons sur bfm tv
à 13h mercredi dernier donc je pense
qu'en termes d' écoute mais quand même
plutôt pas mal j'ai pas besoin de venir
me mettre même limite en danger parce qu
imaginer qu'il soit justement l'auteur
baisser la question je vous imaginez
bien là vous avez justement vous avez
votre réponse c'est que moi je crois
sincèrement là j'en suis persuadé il
vient ni aussant qui en prison et
effectivement j'ai la naïveté je suis
peut-être un peu puéril vous savez mais
moi j'aime bien défendre les gens et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'étais
dans la police et un peu plus tard dans
le syndicalisme arriver frais bocage
j'aurais pu l'être effectivement
d'ailleurs avec mourad ben atiq nous
sommes rendu compte que nous sommes
connus ensemble au séminaire de l'ihd
est de l'institut des études de la
défense nationale nous aurions pu avoir
la même trajectoire on était ensemble en
séminaire en 2000 le jour où tu viens
vous défendre mais bien sûr moi si un
jour vous rade batik été mis en cause et
que j'avais des éléments pour le
défendre je les ferai valoir le la en
l'espèce le cédric je me marre je n'ai
eu plusieurs fois au téléphone cédric
gillard c'est quelqu'un qui m'a aidé
quand j'avais des malfaçons sur ma
maison a à faire valoir mes droits parce
que je l'aimé placo qui était moisi
cédric jubilaire c'est quelqu'un avec
qui j'avais une relation certes à
distance mais qui m'a énormément aidé et
moi je ne suis quelqu'un qui rend ça et
vous savez là vous me parlez vous avez
trouvé sur internet mais ce n'est sur
twitter en viennent avant tout ça moi
j'avais envoyé des messages de soutien
cédric jubilaire sur facebook et ça
personne ne le voyez à paris jean qui
était ami avec lui ou actuellement mois
et ses messages twitter un message sur
messenger et sur facebook me sont
revenus via twitter des personnes qui me
disait regardez le policier corrompu qui
soutiennent le meurtrier mais en fait
non moi je suis quelqu'un qui soutient
sincèrement quelques que j'ai apprécié
au plan humain voyez et c'est aussi pour
ça que je suis là aujourd'hui si j'avais
voulu me faire de la publicité au plan
politique déjà notre effet annoncé en
tant que tel un et si quelqu'un ne sais
pas qui je suis je fais de la télé fait
30 ans que ça marche pas comme ça non
mais
je l'avais sa famille jubilaire juste un
mot pour qu on recentre un petit peu sur
le dossier parce que bien sûr elle n'est
pas là du rassemblement national ou
d'autre part marine et plus
vous avez rejoint reconquête non j'ai
apporté mon soutien et la demande des
nuances entre les doigts je rejoins
roquettes
tout état de cause moi ça m'indiffère
mois celui que j'entends aujourd'hui est
celui qui défend la position de vous
défendre aujourd'hui c'est l'amie de
cédric jubilaire je vais partir code ce
postulat est uniquement de ce postulat
est ce postulat c'est celui d'un ami et
ça peut être celui des avocats de la
défense et c'est celui globalement de
ceux qui émettent un doute sur la
culpabilité de cédric jubilaire moi je
suis pas là pour définir la culpabilité
c'est pas mon rôle ça n'est pas le rôle
de l'avocat des parties civiles c'est le
rôle du parquet c'est le rôle des
magistrats instructeurs c'est le rôle
des officiers de police judiciaire qui
s'en charge de ce dossier - j'attire
simplement la tire simplement
l'attention de ceux qui se posent la
question sur ce dossier et qui disent
que ce dossier est vide eh bien je suis
aussi là pour pour pour dire que ce
dossier il est tout sauf évident qu'il y
a des éléments à charge qu'il ya des
indices graves et concordants qui ont
permis aux magistrats instructeurs de
place et cédric jubila en détention ce
qui a été confirmé par la chambre
d'instruction à de multiples reprises et
donc je ne peux pas laisser passer le
fait que l'on dise à longueur de journée
que ce dossier il est vide il ya le
secret de l'instruction qui m'empêche de
dévoiler l'intégralité des éléments à
charge contre cédric jubilaire mais vous
imaginez les moyens colossaux qui ont
été déployés dans ce dossier toutes les
pistes ont été explorées jusqu'au bout
du bout et donc si in fine et cédric
girard restent en détention provisoire
alors que des gendarmes alors que
l'armée de terre a été déployé dans les
fouilles alors que des magistrats
instructeurs de manière collégiale
travail de suie nuitées jour alors que
ça a été confirmé par la chambre
imaginez bien que votre position d'amis
elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut et elle est
loyal à tout le moins on pourra pas vous
enlever ça mais elle ne fait pas le
poids face aux arguments factuels qui
sont dans le dossier et auquel j'ai
accès les arguments factuels auquel j'ai
accès ils ne sont quand même assez
solide j'en ai dit certains il y en a
d'autres l'instruction on en est à peu
près à la moitié de l'instruction donc
tout le travail n'a pas été fait on l'a
dit avec cyril d'ici le 31 mars il ya
déjà des expertises qui vont rentrer qui
vont positionné un peu plus cédric
jubilaire face à ce dossier face aux
accusations auxquelles il doit faire
auxquels il doit faire face et où je
dire on avance tranquillement on avance
sereinement mais je crois qu'il faut
arrêter un moment de dire que ce dossier
est vide ça n'a à mon sens aucun scoop
man